ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show we are here very exciting I
just tipped a woman 41 in Starbucks
remember that Bruce Springsteen song 41
Shots that he did when Amadou Diallo was
shot by the police 41 shot all of
Bruce's fans I was at his concert once I
don't know 99 2000 something and all of
the Long Island fans and uh pretty much
everyone they all went for like a
cigarette during that song because that
was a big like hey the cop should stop
shooting black people song and as soon
as he was like 41 shot everybody
everybody's like let's go get a beer and
then they came back when it was you know
Born in the USA or something they didn't
understand
um uh but I tried and the reason was I
gave her a fifty dollar bill I'm not
saying I'm a good person I don't do this
a lot but I do I do tip people well
um but and I don't do crazy stuff like
I'm not you know I'm not the the you
know David dobrik used to go and give
people Lamborghinis and stuff and
you know somebody was in it was mired in
debt and he was like here's a car you
don't know how to drive and
it's worth more than you know it's like
the craziest thing but YouTubers do it
all the time they're like hey today I'm
gonna give my parents money you know
they would go like here with Mom and Dad
I paid off your house and the mom would
cry
I've never done that I'm not doing that
I'm not what am I gonna do buy the
mental institution that my mother lives
in
I'm going to go back to the lunatic
asylum that she's in and go surprise mom
guess what I did I bought the mental
institution that you live in what
what you know this place I bought it I
got in bed with a shady Healthcare
Company we're taking money from the
government we're doing some Medicare
fraud but the good news is you get a
slightly bigger room
I mean no so there's no what am I gonna
do she's in she's in the clink
I didn't uh you know I didn't design her
brain but it's malfunctioned
um and so I never and my father is doing
fine I love him we speak he's doing
great he doesn't need anything these
people on Long Island don't need
anything him and his wife have a lovely
life they drink wine they have dogs they
walk they boat they it's good
it's good if I showed up and paid off
their mortgage they'd be angry with me
they'd think it was some kind of scam
they'd be like who do you think you are
how did you get our information like no
but you can't do anything good for
anyone where I'm from in Long Island it
doesn't work it only puts you at odds
with them long term
so this woman who is a partly a larger
woman which now that I'm working with a
trainer and I've worked with a trainer
for two days and I'm on the My Fitness
you know the fitness pal
it's not always a pal because it'll tell
you some hard truths but you put you put
the thing you know if you eat uh if you
breathe you have to put it in two
breaths and it calculates you know
[__] you you know you go [__] [__]
you know whatever it is you don't do
that but you put in if you eat like a
churro you have to put it you know
churro and you have to and then it tells
you but it tabulates and then you have
less and less at the end of the day and
then the goal is to be all zeros like
your calorie allotment your Macros your
fat your carbs your protein
is all whatever in in line and um and uh
I I so what I realize now is weight is
an issue of class
kind of meaning that
there are people that are overweight
because they they just don't have access
to the same type of food that other
people do now this is obviously a little
abused right as a as an as a people this
is a little bit of a crutch everybody
can find a carrot but not everybody's
gonna eat a carrot and you can't live on
carrots
so my point is when I see somebody
working their ass off and she's a big
woman I'm you know I feel like let me
give her
money so that she can
do something good for herself
or for her family or whatever and I'm
not again I'm not decision I'm trying to
be a good person here I'm just saying
and the reason it happened was because
she didn't have change for the 50 and
she goes do you want to use a
do you want to use a credit card or
Apple pay a friend of mine who's in the
store with me we're in the Coffee Bean
and I said well no I said why don't you
just keep it and this woman was so
horrified
by that by the idea of that she thought
it was like a some type of she goes no
no I can know I said I want you to keep
the money she goes no it's eight dollars
you know it's too much I said no you do
something nice
you do something nice for yourself with
it and then she she somehow makes change
and then puts a change in the tip cup
because take your money
and I'm like
no and I'm wondering is she like an
addict can she not have cash is there
like a reason she doesn't have cash is
she gonna take forty dollars right now
and go buy something she shouldn't have
a rock I don't know what she's gonna do
right like she was so terrified by that
and in Los Angeles displays of kindness
are so incredibly rare that I understand
so I told her I was like I'm I I was a
tour guide on a double decker bus I used
to rely on tips and no a lot of people
didn't tip
and there was a black guy in the thing
and he was like you a tall guy you're a
tour manager and I was like no I was a
guide I would show people the buildings
he's like damn and I was like he was so
he's a cool guy and then he's like what
do you do now I'm like oh I'm a comedian
he's like you're a comedian and then we
looked up
so then you feel like a piece of [__]
and we looked up the Netflix special and
she's like I'm gonna watch it the good
deed's over it's been completely washed
away now by like there's people in there
going what is wrong with this man
so people are going to see me go this
guy this guy is harassing people to
watch his [__] Netflix special at the
Coffee Bean all I tried to do is quietly
give this woman forty dollars for her to
go buy drugs
and she didn't do it but that's what I
mean about the pitfalls of uh being nice
I'm doing a lot I do a lot of shows in
L.A and they've been a lot of fun and
we've been talking about the Ukraine a
lot on the podcast and on the show and a
lot of people have told me they said
well you seem pretty uh you seem pretty
like anti-ukraine and I'm not
anti-ukraine I'm anti taking the
American war machine's word for it about
any conflict anywhere in the world and
if you are not an idiot you would be too
I feel horrible for the people of
Ukraine we had a kid on a comedian on
when this first thing when they started
you know uh seven eight months ago ten
months ago and we had him on and you
know it was uh incredibly sad what
they're going through I don't think
anybody is happy about that I've been
somebody that wants that to end I don't
want nuclear Holocaust I don't want a
war that destroys all of Ukraine I don't
want any of that I I don't know what's
gonna happen I I hope that you know I've
always hoped that Russia would say okay
we're done but it doesn't seem like
that's realistic with Russia's current
leadership in fact they keep mobilizing
people they're they're calling up more
troops the attacks are getting worse and
worse and worse
so and when the American war machine
goes we'll support Ukraine no matter
what no matter how long wink it means
they want a 30-year Cold War
that will just destroy Russia and bleed
Russia out and make people hear a lot of
money instead of forcing some type of
agreement
um or even trying for some type of
um so again it's not and again I'm not
you don't absolve Rush huh they invaded
the Ukraine they invaded a sovereign
country Wars are never good Wars are
never about you know one thing usually
they're more complex and what bothers me
is the narrative that everybody is fed
all the time in this country is like
good evil
right wrong there's and here's the line
and if you even go well why is that that
you're like yeah with that it's not
it's not realistic
uh that people are not gonna have
questions you're not going to go wait
wait what the [__] going on explain to
me what's going on we I just want to
know what's going on so I'm going to
play a a battle right now and this is
something I'm really serious on the show
but I'm gonna be serious right now
because this is disturbing to me I
there's Carnage going on in the Ukraine
right now there's Carnage
and it's something and I'm actually
texting an attorney I don't even know if
we can play this this is footage that I
got
from a person on the front lines
that's footage that I got from a person
on the front lines and
um
it's it's one of those things where
uh I'm worried as a broadcaster because
if I play this footage
and it Alters the course of the war or
something happens
and I but this is literally this has not
been seen on the media
this is footage from the front lines
sent to me from what's going on in
Russia in the Ukraine right now I'm dead
serious I just got the okay from my
attorney
I'm telling you right now if you have
children in the room this is not for
them but as adults we all have to
understand the stakes and what's going
on play it
[Music]
all right
yo mama
I don't know it's hard to watch that
and I don't know which side admittedly
because they all look so similar I don't
know which side is is Wyland
but Russia or the Ukraine someone was
wylin and then someone
came in and then fixed that but what I'm
saying here is that the war is a problem
okay and we need to figure out a
solution
if we're going to keep seeing scenes
like that
I mean it's crazy and we're we're we are
the the United States is sending in the
equipment they're sending in the waffle
irons they're sending in the coffee
burner they're sending in the griddles
to make the hash browns smothered and
covered they're they're sending in the
Machinery of death
so that this war can go on
that wasn't that wasn't the Ukraine it
was a Waffle House
see that's
they don't have Waffle Houses in the
Ukraine otherwise things would be
peaceful like they are here hello
can you hear me
my name is hell afresh you get farm
fresh pre-portioned ingredients for your
seasonal cooking recipes
delivered right to your doorstep get
trips to the grocery store and count on
hello fresh to make home cooking easy
and fun and affordable that's why it's
America's meal number one meal kit I'm
telling you right now you know what's so
easy for me is when I wake up and I have
a pre-planned routine of food
and if you're like me and you're on the
go are you on the go are you on the go
you're on the go because what happens in
this world
is you're just so like busy with
everything with the kids and the wife
and the husband and the job and the
traffic and the politics and the family
and the dogs and the cats and everybody
it's just you're being pulled in a
million different directions and you
don't have time to make a nutritious
meal for everybody and you've got New
Year's goals and a little fresher's here
to help you achieve them skip the
grocery store take control of your time
and budget with delicious recipes
delivered right to your door
hello fresh is festive Fair collection
features limited time recipes with
seasonal produce and premium proteins
get out of the post holiday slump with
these elevated winter Classics looking
for an easy way to eat well and save
money this year cut back on expensive
takeout and delivery get started with
hello fresh you'll love how fast easy
and affordable is to whip up restaurant
quality meal right in your own kitchen
it's fun you get the recipes you get the
food you get to cook in the kitchen you
get that little glass of wine you know
and everything's right there and you
have the you know what I mean
you can you can have baby back ribs
chocolate chip brownies and everything
in between I love that that's tailored
for my audience it's like not it's like
nothing healthy
they're like it's called hellofreshed
and look at my audience they're like you
can have butter cake
and baked beans
like I'm sure like somebody else's
audience they're like you know Mandarin
Chicken Salad my audience is like don't
you want baby back ribs how about some
cookies I've tried hellofresh I have it
I use it it's great I love cooking in my
kitchen with the ingredients that I get
from a farm and that's what makes me
feel good I look at my kids and my wife
and I say look at the meal that I've
just made and they say thank you very
much most of them one of them is
non-verbal
but we're figuring that out go to
hellofresh.com
timd21 and use code timd21 for 21 free
meals plus free shipping
go to hellofresh.com
timd21 and use code timd21 for 21 free
meals plus
um but goodness a new plan he's calling
up these drug addicts and this is by the
way I am a big fan of this as an idea
because I've been a drug addict many
would say I still am uh my addictions
and compulsions come out with food and
cigarettes and all kinds of things and I
try to keep them I try to keep them down
and choose the light but drug addicts
can be very useful
um they don't have anything to live for
this is what's good about a drug addict
in a war they have nothing to deliver if
you were in the depths of drug and by
the way if you're in the depths of drug
addiction don't use this as some excuse
to do something heinous you know what
I'm saying clean yourselves up but I'm
saying if you're really in the depths of
a drug addiction you really don't have
anything to live for you don't care
about anything else except the drug so
those people are bodies that can be
thrown into conflict
let's do a close-up Russia sends drug
addicts uh to war to mobilization uh
numbers here now close up on these guys
these are the guys that I think may turn
the tide go all the way to the right
look at this guy he's look the the
little guy is great Rogan is fighting
with him but no to the right go all the
way to this guy he's he that guy is
drunk right now
he's hammered right now and
I I like the look of this this is a
Motley Crew you know it reminds me of
the sandblot remember the movie The
Sandlot we'd have a bunch of you know
it's like neighborhood kids and they're
like they're a scraggly rat pack of you
got the fat kid and the ginger and the
skinny kid and The Wimp And then
everybody's gonna come together at the
end
and kill people in the Ukraine that I
think is this because it's a Motley Crew
of junkies and drug addicts and people
that are in Russian prisons for stealing
and stuff and what Putin has said is you
have a chance to regain your glory
by going to the Ukraine and fighting and
I think it's a fun like it's a
we know everything you know we this is
we don't want a war we don't want a war
to happen but if it gives Russian
convicts and drug addicts a purpose
it's not it's not all for naught like we
want you know and if you look at these
men they just seem ready
they seem ready to go
they seem ready to go they seem excited
and they're ready to go let's read a
little bit of this article to see
so Ukrainian intelligence believes that
Russian President Putin is preparing to
announce another wave of mobilization
and here's the thing all of these things
are War propaganda from both sides we
don't know what's true but that's the
fun
Russia is sending drug addicts to war in
an effort to meet its mobilization quota
the information about the massive
mobilization of drug addicts was it's
amazing like with these drug addicts
like they're just the information about
the massive wave of drug addicts was
confirmed by one of the Russian soldiers
who surrendered to the resistance
movement according to him he was not
cured of addiction and continues to use
drugs while fighting and I'm not even
going to try to pronounce it zafarazia
the man took the drugs with him his
medicine well why would you stop drugs
in the Ukrainian War
could there be less of a reason to get
sober than fighting a war in the Ukraine
and so I I don't know where they're
finding these drug addicts where are
they getting them
are they just getting them off the
street
are they going into the schools
convicts offered a ratio of criminal
records if they serve here we go
to leverage people into enlisting the
Kremlin has weaved leniency into
long-standing legislation meaning like
they're getting a little desperate now
they're like let's get the criminals
let's get the junkies and bring them
over
yeah
I think that's a good idea
I think it's a good idea you have a
bunch of
is that the azov battalion's [__]
uniforms
they look sick as [__]
dude how sick
that's what they're fighting in in
beanies
like that
is this war even happening is this a Wag
the Dog no I think it is happening but
I will say that um
you know I feel like we're in the end of
it now I feel like we're it's kind of
like Avatar in a third hour
I was like wrap it up like I feel like
we're getting to that point with it now
where it's like you know we're cut
people are kind of like hey
yeah too much cinnamon go get that money
back
um
Elizabeth Holmes by the way did you hear
this you expect now Elizabeth Holmes is
this [__] who was selling these fake
bloody meters to diabetics because she
had all these people invested in uh this
theranos company you know bad blood is
the book and the movie and all that
stuff and basically if she got sentenced
and she then tried to flee to Mexico she
tried to flee after conviction I mean I
mean it's the woman see she first of all
she only got 11 years it's not a lot
I've talked about this before this is
not enough to dissuade anybody from
doing this she was giving people fake
blood tests didn't work
giving people a test where they've got I
think I'm okay
I mean that's the human cost of this
they give her 11 years in jail and the
[__]
wants to go to Mexico
she tries to flee and I guess they catch
her
I mean it's like
listen to this
the government here we go prosecutors
said in a filing that Holmes legal
defense had argued that she had a
Flawless pre-trial record
but does not mention her quote attempt
to flee they said the government learned
that January 23rd 2022 that Holmes
booked a one-way flight to Mexico
scheduled for January 26th but a return
flight was not scheduled well I do that
a lot you book one you don't know when
you're coming back
the government then mentioned the trip
to Holmes's defense attorney and the
flight was canceled after that
she was probably just trying to go see
Mexico
she's probably just trying to go
get her Margaritas on and see the
beautiful ancient Mayan ruins and yet
She's accused of
fling she's surrendering herself to
custody on April uh 27th we hope
or she'll flee again Elizabeth Holmes
we've got our eyes on you
I read that book with uh you know with
the
look at her she's she's just
she's one of those people she thought it
would work
you know some of these people they
really think the thing you know because
everybody's told this horse [__] when
they grow up
that like you can believe you're like
just believe believe and then that you
know
can lead to good things where people are
like I lost 10 pounds you know and then
whatever you know but then believe could
be you just start selling fake blood
tests to diabetics that's also and you
go just believe it'll work believe and
she you know she constantly looks like
she's in some kind of catatonic State
like she's not fully with us on planet
Earth like she's just kind of glazed
over Elizabeth Holmes she's yeah there's
a glaze to her look at that there's a
glaze to her she's not fully here
shall fully hear she's there's something
she's somewhere else
listening to the song you know we were
at The Improv the other night and a
woman came busting in the green room and
started telling Trevor Wallace about his
higher self
and she's like she goes your higher self
he's the girl in your shoes your higher
self came to me during the thing she
goes I'm a I'm a whatever and I'm a
spiritual whatever they call themselves
and she goes I'm sitting here on your
higher self
um came to me and said uh that your soul
mate was the girl from the joke where
you have some joke about a girl making
fun of you for eating carrot cake and
she goes your higher self came to me and
said that that is your soul mate and
then Trevor Wallace was like okay and
Trevor Wallace actually is dating that
girl now so it was kind of weird you
know
and then I was like did my higher self
say anything about the Ukraine to you
because I talked a little bit about that
did my higher self get involved one of
the most exciting things about a new
year is that you have no idea what
Adventures are in store for you from new
travel experiences to new jobs to
picking up new skills there's no better
way to prepare for 2023 than by learning
a new language with Babel Babel is the
only language learning app that sold
more than 10 million subscriptions
thanks to Babel's addictively fun and
easily bite-sized language lessons you
can eat everything's food from my
audience huh bite-sized language lessons
fry up some lessons with Babel with
Babel you only need 10 minutes to
complete a lesson you can start having
real life conversations in a new
language in as little as three weeks
other language learning apps use AI for
their lesson plans but Baba lessons were
created by over 150 language experts and
voiced by real native speakers not
computers their teaching method has been
and when America Falls where are you
gonna go and how are you going to
communicate
Bible speech recognition technology
helps you improve your pronunciation and
accent
so Babel teaches you not only how to
speak in the language but how to do the
very cringe-worthy accent
there are so many ways to learn with
Babel in additional lessons you can
access podcast Games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20-day money-back guarantee start your
language learning Journey today with the
Baba
that's the way foreign
right now get up to 55 off your
subscription when you go to
babel.comtim that's bad and I'm gonna
I've been doing this because I want to
learn other languages and it's actually
been working
me gusta ellado
that's babel.com Tim for up to 55 off
your subscription that's babel.com Tim
for 55 off your subscription Babble
language for life
are I like Greta thundberg now and I'll
tell you it's been a while since I've
checked in on her what I like about hers
in the beginning like Greta thundberg
was just kind of like you know you kind
of like annoying environmental like I
don't want to go to school and you you
better start using brown toilet paper
and planes are gross you know but now
she's evolved into this Joker type
character who I think wants to just blow
things up like a real eco-terrorist and
I think she just wants to like burn
things down and strike fear into the
hearts of men which I kind of like even
though this is all set up the Germans
here's the thing with the Germans when
you make soap out of a race of people
you really have to do a lot on the back
nine to make up for that so what they do
all the time is they really just let
left-wing lunatics do a lot of crazy
[__] because most people enjoy a lot of
people in Germany are Nazis and it
wouldn't take much for them to be Nazis
again like if they knew there was a
pathway for them to go right back to
being Nazis they would be Nazis because
that was the period of German greatness
truly and I don't mean it was good it
was bad but to the to German
nationalists that was their era right so
what the German government tries to do
is they try to like they go the other
way where they let they like let all the
migrants in and some of them the some of
them are going to Goose you on New
Year's enough you know don't complain
that Turkish guy grabbed your tent we
made soap out of people you gotta let
this stuff happen the Turkish guy got a
little handsy in the Mart sorry we made
soap out of people we gotta let this
[__] happen so that's really what it is
truly that's the drug they go on the
other they're a little bit and they have
some weird s m stuff you know they they
like they they they they tie businessmen
and stuff to tables and they [__] on
glass and they jerk off under it they're
in the blood and piss play and stuff and
it's all very deep repressed kind of but
but some kind of cool in a way and they
have these Raves and underground tunnels
in Berlin so Greta thundberg is being
detained at the is protest and and and
the German police they've kind of set
this up because the police are told
obviously we can't
hurt Greta thundberg
she seems kind of German right the name
thundberg it seems a little like they're
like listen
we have to deal with her but we're going
to arrest her and they're saying of
course that it is not like a um that it
wasn't stagecraft like it was real but
you know it's fake because they've
caught video there's video of the cops
and Greta kind of having but by the way
I've been arrested and I've had cops be
kind of friendly to me and I've said a
funny thing and they've laughed at it
and that wasn't a fake arrest but
there's videos supposedly of Greta being
arrested and she's she's it's kind of
like uh cute around like this is good
that she's smiling it's kind of like the
the media's there
have everybody knows everybody knows
what you know she's
doing what they should have done is like
if they wanted to look she's standing
there she knows how this is all gonna go
this is all you know like programmed
ahead of time
and
what they should have done is they
should have choreographed it where she's
thrown to the ground and they put their
boots on her and they they rip her hands
behind her back and carry her out like
you ever see the scene in the casino
where Pesci's like open the door with
his head like that that should have been
the way they took her out just like a
like like a battering ram and they
shouldn't have heard her but it would
have made it more realistic you know
because they're in those Stormtrooper
outfits but yet they're carrying her out
like a little baby so what you're seeing
is like nobody's Satisfied by this
that you know I would if if I was
directing this which someone is I'd be
like more struggle Greta honey
struggle get her on the ground we're
gonna get her underground then you guys
put the boots on her we want to see you
struggle on the ground we're gonna snap
the arms back behind you we're gonna
pick you up you're gonna be screaming
okay maybe a muzzle should she bite
should she spit
okay would take two Greta it's it's not
gonna be biting honey but it's gonna be
spit you're gonna spit at them
yes yes that's a good idea so when you
spit at him you're spitting at him he's
going to maybe smack you like like a
mime smack kind of smack and then once
you've spit it'll then it gives them the
direction when now they're going to have
to Muzzle you you understand because in
this scene honey honey are you with us
today okay we just gotta Focus we're
losing light we're shooting and we're
losing light so here's what in this
scene you're very very angry because
what are they even protesting what are
they protesting here the Greta thundberg
oh a coal mine so honey in this scene
your V your your girl uh from the you
know whatever what does she Dutch
Denmark Sweden Swedish Greta you're a
Swedish girl and you're famous and you
hate the coal mine because this Coal
Mine makes the air black and when you
breathe in you don't get the Sweet Air
you get just the tar of the coal and you
don't like that and you're very angry
and you see these cops and the cops come
in and they represent everything that is
wrong patriarchy militarism capitalism
and they come in with their their big
batons these phallic symbols but you you
see you Greta you stand there and you
kind of stand your ground and they're
going to take you into custody the young
girl protecting us all saving us from
ourselves now when they take you into
custody you have to struggle you have to
fight a little bit uh because they're
gonna eventually Muzzle you you spit it
one of them and then they come in and
they puzzle you and then we can see but
I think what happened was then they got
notes
this is what happens sometimes when
you're in a production and somebody goes
here's your reality the studio feels
that this needs to be it needs to feel
more symbolic
we don't want to see Greta roughed up we
don't want to see her spitting and we
don't want to see her put in a muzzle
we've really decided that the move here
is just to carry her out kind of
respectfully we don't want to walk her
out because that seems too easy so we do
want the shot of him carrying her but
we're gonna mix the spitting and the
muzzle okay okay Greta change of plans
honey you can go to craft Services get
her a juice no spitting no Muzzle no
struggle on the ground they are going to
lift you up and they are going to take
you out as they're taking you out you do
a light smile because you're smiling
because all of your ideas about the
world have been made real by these scary
men that are taking you you understand
that and this is how in five years we
could take everybody's car yes that's
the goal this is how five years we take
everyone's car so we just want to get
this perfect ready and action and that's
what they do it's a production but you
know I would have said make it a little
more rough but apparently somebody came
in and said you know because Germany's
trying to they're trying to emerge as
the moral leader of Europe
which is tough to do when you have the
past that they do
so what you're seeing happen is they're
trying to be very delicate and handle
these situations very artfully and I
think they did a decent enough job with
this one I like Greta I like her because
you know everyone's got a part to play
in this world
everybody does and she's doing it well
it's not Academy Award yet
dad
nobody starts out Robert Pattinson
they start out as one of these idiots on
the Cobra Kai and then they if they're
good they get to that thing I've talked
about ship station for so many years and
everybody I know who's tried it
including me is so happy because they
handle all the back end all the shipping
if you have an e-commerce business you
need to be focusing on you know lead
generation marketing getting new clients
acquisition this is the move the front
office is the most important part the
back office is just to facilitate
getting your product shipped making sure
everybody's happy it shouldn't be
stressful running a business can be
stressful but using ship station is easy
they work with all of the major shippers
it's amazing how easy they make it you
can automate one simple dashboard all
these routine shipping tasks print
shipping labels easily compare rates and
delivery times to optimize every
shipment and automate delivery
notifications and with Enterprise
solutions that make Warehouse
optimization easy ship station scales
when you do
with the best discounts in the industry
you'll never worry about overpaying for
shipping get up to 88 off USPS and UPS
rates and if that's not enough use my
promo code try ship station free for two
months over a hundred and thirty
thousand companies have grown their
e-commerce businesses with ship station
and 98 of companies that stick with ship
station for a year become customers for
life
keep growing your business all year long
with ship station you know my friend
makes little voodoo dolls and sends them
to people and they curse people that
have wronged them and she uses ship
station
and it's been amazing for her she's a
thriving business of selling these
voodoo dolls
use promo code Tim Dillon today at
shipstation.com to sign up for your free
60-day trial that's
shipstation.com promo code Tim Dillon
friend and this is you know a sad story
we don't love this Alec Baldwin who's a
friend of the show and was very kind to
us he had me on his podcast and he's a
you know he's a he's a real star you
know and he's again he's done there's
some things he's done that you know
obviously you wouldn't co-sign the
shooting of the lady
um but we don't he do it on purpose it
seems weird that he would do it on
purpose right so they're trying him for
involuntary
um manslaughter I love this Alec Baldwin
Church PR expert says star on Hollywood
Blacklist it's like what about the
involuntary manslaughter jar isn't that
more important so he won't do the Trump
impression this year it's like on SNL
it's like what about the involuntary
manslaughter but it's weird because this
is how I understand it Alec Baldwin gets
to the set
um I don't know why there's a real
bullet in this gun it seems weird
Alec Baldwin uh the person who put the
bullet in the gun is also being charged
and I believe with involuntary
manslaughter this costume design or this
props matter you know I was just on a
thing where we had props I was on this
film and maybe my scenes and it will see
and um you would go and we'd get props
and then the props would you know you
would you would go and they would put
the pr I can't talk about it so I can't
tell you what the props were but you get
the props at the beginning of the day
you would deprop at the end of the day
you would give them their props and
nobody shot anybody in the face
now
so this so that okay so Alec Baldwin and
the armorer they call it the armorer
well that's a creepy but the armorer
will be charged uh with the same thing
which is the involuntary manslaughter
after fatal shooting of Hal Nia Hutchins
on the set of rust
the movie here and um okay so that
woman's name is Hannah Gutierrez read
she's the film's armorer and each will
be charged with two counts of
involuntary manslaughter play that up
there I wonder what that is he's
reacting to this he's unhappy I don't
know if this is him reacting but this is
this is the chaotic moments after the
shooting of Russ so after Alec Baldwin
has shot This Woman This is a oh
uh doesn't it okay it's an ad
[__] the ad fooled me I thought
we were getting Rick Rolled yeah
but here so we have
we have this is footage right after
right now does Alec in this seem he
seems distressed he's a he's not he's
unhappy with this I would hope like this
this thing is like he's not happy so
this is right after we have volume on
this
Bank
questions now
now questioning at any time or to stop
thank you I got uh just Santa Fe
if I'm standing there
okay well it does seem he does seem
remarkably composed
after it it doesn't seem like the
greatest doesn't seem like the greatest
you know I was there in rehearsal I was
asking myself
um but I met him and I I do not believe
he did this on purpose so I don't know
you know I from from what I believe but
I also don't believe to be fair is fair
I want to be fair here maybe he'll call
me and scream at me after this but like
I I feel like he's a person that maybe
he doesn't have as much empathy as he
should he may lack a little bit of
empathy and I think part of that is
because being in the in the system for
as long as he's been in it
he may not have the empathy or he may
just not show the empathy like I don't
when I met him I felt like number one he
didn't do it on purpose because why
would he do it but number two uh
was he keeping up up at night I don't
know if it was keeping him up and not I
think he slept soundly I think I think
he was sleeping soundly and and not
again not that I'm saying that somebody
should go to jail for sleeping soundly
but it's come off a little bit like I
don't know that there's been the
requisite amount of Mia culpa after
shooting someone in the eye and um yeah
it's his composure that that's the thing
it's there's no like oh my God is she
okay how did this happen I can't believe
it I shot somebody it's more like
earlier in rehearsal I was
how could I ever how could you ever
would anyone believe I would just shoot
this woman and she'd fall to the ground
but these are actors and when you were a
real actor and I've done this over and
over again I'm not going to explain it
again but I will for one minute repeat
myself and go these people they're
always kind of acting if they're good
and he's good
and I I just think that he's playing
that role in the role is kind of a valik
Baldwin he's playing that role so when
he comes across like that it I don't
know that you know most people if if
somebody told me
hey the film that I was just on if
somebody told me you just shot someone
in the face by mistake I would hope by
the way I would hope I'd be inconsolable
like a mother of however many kids like
if I killed a per like you would think
I'd be in console I'd be throwing myself
on the floor crying no my kids no and
how did it happen maybe I wouldn't but
this is what I'd hope I but but the
composure that he has is I think what
disturbs people has he reacted to this
has Alec Baldwin because supposedly he's
raging behind the scenes this is what
people are saying obviously we don't
know if it's true but he's very angry
because I think he was kind of he was
gonna have a little comeback I would
have loved to do something with him you
know he called me and
you know he said like maybe there's a
sitcom for us he really even said that
which I would have loved to do listen
because everybody's on a black you know
he shot a woman I sat next to Alex Jones
you know hey let's all you know we move
on we do a fun said comment everybody
you know everybody gets over it but um
so he hasn't but his wife has oh Hilaria
has and she's doing the Spanish accent
but I think she should be allowed to
first of all she's under duress I've
always supported uh her her uh you know
need to be any race she wants what is
she saying now
we by the way we support
and to be there when they come home is
not good
so on a human level they have seven
children is not good
they have seven kids
he never stopped having kid it's like
imagine having to explain this
to seven children
one child it would be hard seven times
daddy shot someone at work
seven times daddy shot someone at work
waffle daddy shot someone at work waffle
daddy shot someone at work waffle daddy
shot someone at work because one of
them's a vegan probably Sprouts daddy
shot someone at work but just the idea
of that
such a large fan I mean God bless God
bless him we're listen we support the
Baldwins because he might get out of
this somehow and have it I would love to
be a part of like his return
it's a sitcom pictured Spacey Baldwin
Dylan no yes I love Helix in my house in
Long Island we have all these Helix beds
they're less expensive than other beds
I've bought but they're actually the
best beds everybody loves the Helix pads
it's true Helix sleep is a premium
mattress brand that provides tailored
mattresses based on your unique sleep
preferences so if you're a fat even
batty you will maybe require some type
of firmer mattress that you will still
depress with the size of your mask but
it won't take as long okay they have a
mattress for Big and Tall sleepers and
even a mattress Mage is for kids so how
do you know which Helix mattress works
best for you you take the Helix sleep
quiz and find your perfect mattress in
under two minutes and your personalized
mattress is shipped straight to your
door free of charge Helix knows there's
no better way to test out a new mattress
than by sleeping on it in on your in in
your in your baby in your baby okay
sorry do this again
Helix knows there's no better way to
test out a new mattress than by sleeping
on it in your own home that's why they
offer 100 night risk free trial try out
your new Helix mattress see how your
body adjusts and if you decide it's not
the best fit you're welcome to return
for a full refund everybody is unique
everybody sleeps differently my aunt for
example in the middle of the night she
gets up and screams and she's gotten a
knife and runs in the backyard so
everybody has a different she starts
screaming they think she's regressing
she has these she went to this therapist
and what the therapist is they did past
life regression therapy and in her past
life she believed she was a Nazi a
Nazi's wife a high-ranking member and
she feels very guilty about that so
that's why in the in the yard she goes
with a knife and screams we don't know
but this but she loves but since she got
a helix mattress she does not do this as
much not only is the mattress the best
I've slept on but the setup was fast and
easy Helix mattresses are delivered in a
box and straight to your door for free
plus Helix mattresses are American made
and come with a 10 to 15 year warranty
depending on the model and remember you
will get to try it out for 109th
literally I've advertised a lot of [__]
on the show I'll be very honest with you
they gave me these mattresses for free
because we kind of asked them to
I have bought tempur-pedics I've spent
thousands of dollars on mattresses these
are the most comfortable mattresses I'm
not even lying these are the most
comfortable mattresses that I have and
they were inexpensive they were free for
me but they were inexpensive for you and
literally everybody that stayed in my
house on Long Island everybody goes the
where are where did you get these things
literally everyone and I say Helix and
I'm not lying about this is genuinely
amazing like when we did all those FTX
reads you know we didn't we should have
done more due diligence but this I am
not [__] around with I have these
things we sleep on them
and they're made in America by Americans
and that matters Helix is offering up to
200 off all mattress orders and two free
pillows for our listeners go to Helix
sleep.com slash Tim D
ude Helix is offering up to 200 did you
hear that off all mattress orders and
two free pillows for our listeners go to
helixsleep.com Tim D with Helix better
sleep starts now
here's the thing I agree with her I
agree with Hilaria that uh they should
let it play out uh you know at the end
of the day this is a tragic thing a
woman has lost your life uh there's
going to be a court case about this it's
going to be handled and
you know
we can't we you know we stand back here
but I mean you know I don't I don't
think Alec Baldwin did it on purpose
um do I think that he is
you know maybe his his way he's talked
about has been a little callous and you
know people have been maybe disappointed
by that but here's the thing I'll say
about Alec is that everyone Grieves in
different ways
everyone Grieves in different ways and
maybe his way to grieve This Woman's
death is to be stoic maybe he's being
strong Alec might be he might be being
strong
and some people go oh he doesn't care he
shot that woman he doesn't care he only
he's only thinking about his career
but also maybe he's just being strong
and don't we need strength
don't we need it this chat bot this
Google chat bot
everybody is up in arms over this Google
is now calling in help from Larry Page
and Sergey Brin uh because this chat bot
is getting everybody up in arms last
month Larry Page and Sergey brand
Google's Founders and by the way we got
to cover these things
because
these stories are eventually uh going to
become your life
whether it affects you now or not it's
going to affect you eventually
um
so Google's Founders held several
meetings with company Executives the
topic arrivals new chatbot
a clever AI product that looked as if it
could be the first notable threat in
decades to Google's 149 billion dollar
search business Mr Page and Mr Brynn who
had not spent much time at Google since
they left their daily roles with the
company reviewed Google's AI product
strategy according to a couple of people
with knowledge of the meetings who are
not allowed to discuss and they approved
plans and pitched ideas to put more
chatbot features into Google search
engine and they offered advice to
company leaders who have put AI front
and center in their plans the
re-engagement of Google's Founders
emphasized the urgency
felt among many Google Executives about
artificial intelligence and the chat bot
the bot which was released by the small
San Francisco Company open AI two months
ago amazed users by simply explaining
complex Concepts and generating the
Ukraine war and generating ideas from
scratch more important to Google it
looked as if it could offer a new way to
search for information on the internet
so the this chat bot which apparently
will AI is going to they they estimate
that some troubling amount of online
content 80 or 90 something crazy will
eventually just be generated by AI even
even shows like this will be replaced by
some type of chatbot some type of Angry
Irish AI because AI can harness but
meaningless rage and and you know weave
it into some comedic form I imagine so
all of these things are coming and
what's interesting is we're we're when
we talk about things like this we're
documenting the destruction of the human
race and what has happened is Google has
like wait a minute we're destroying the
human race and the need for people to
think on their own and then this small
company out of San Francisco open AI
goes actually
we are also destroying the human race at
a pace that may be quicker than you so
then what happens and this is how
everything gets done in the world Google
flips the [__] out they go code red they
are destroying the human race at a
faster Pace than we are [__] we gotta
get back in the lab and that's
essentially what Google's doing but make
no mistake what AI is
artificial intelligence is going to
replace human intelligence this is what
people want
this is what will make things more
efficient
uh art is going to come from AI nfts are
already coming from AI all of this stuff
right basically uh AI is replacing human
function at a kind of an alarming rate
and it's even scarier
when you think about where this
eventually goes
you know and uh what happens to people
um yeah the new AI technology has shaken
Google out of his routine they declared
a code red
and they they're now jump starting AI
development Google Now intends to unveil
more than 20 new products and
demonstrate a version of its search
engine with chatbot features this year
so Google's like [__] it we're we're in
our chat Bots gonna be better our chat
bot will tell you if your kids are trans
and it'll tell your kids if they're
trans or chat bot will get rid of you
quicker than their chat bot will
eliminate you so this is the real debate
here it's interesting
Mr Brandon Mr Page have taken a
laissez-faire approach to Google
but this has scared them
when someone else got to that this is
how all the things in Silicon Valley
happen one person goes I can do it and
then another person goes well actually
I've already kind of done it and then
another person goes [__] and then the
fight to make it happen makes it happen
much quicker so we can start eliminating
human beings maybe in a couple of years
as opposed to 10 or 15. like we can
really we could really get in there what
is the chat let's look at again what a
chat bot is I mean AI we all kind of
know what it is it's artificial uh
intelligence it's technology that can
think and generate ideas I mean somebody
explained it to me once they're like
what if you as a person could read every
book ever written instantly uh you know
these and this is what Elon Musk talks
about all the time he goes if we don't
merge with artificial intelligence we
will be defeated by artificial
intelligence this is something that Elon
Musk believes this is why we have
norlink
and that's that's kind of what he's
doing with Twitter you know it's kind of
interesting he's going if we don't merge
with Nazis we will become Nazis which I
like you know he goes we'll be defeated
by them if we don't kind of merge with
them so we have to kind of let's start
the merger process but yeah I mean it's
a it's a it's creepy all this stuff but
there's nothing there's nothing about it
uh that can be stopped
and there's nothing about it that
anybody wants to stop everybody is
basically just like waiting for these
people to unveil this new product and we
hope and they're just basically hoping
that they have some type of job at the
end of this as soon as the chat bot
comes out they're hoping the chat bot
doesn't destroy their family
they're hoping to chatbot doesn't
destroy their job they're hoping they
can still show up Monday and somebody
doesn't go actually with a chat bot is
now handling that so that's what they're
trying to do they're basically uh just
react we're all reacting none of us have
any clue
and it's not stoppable nobody wants to
go back in time so we're all just gonna
have to figure out how to live with this
technology
and that's I think what you know a lot
of smart people are trying to do and
they're trying to say how soon
are we going to need how soon will I be
advertising chips on this show that will
be implanted in you the shitty chat I
mean we'll get the shittiest chips
we'll get the chips that like you know
they'll be giving them to in sales or
whoever they think our demo is we will
not get the good ships the good chips
will be given out we will get the shitty
chips but they will be something you'll
get something out of it and um
and that'll be uh what we do and we'll
we'll have to Market this stuff what do
we have a choice
that's a thing you know I I I think
we're fully we're fully on board now
with the idea that we just don't have a
choice and it's kind of interesting
the end of humanity is it's a it's a
it's interesting
it's not good and I don't I don't I I
you know but everybody's got to go I
think at some point and I think this is
our time this is our time now to go and
we're clamoring for it I mean there's
companies that are are going to debut
these new products and they're going to
compete as to whose products are better
and the end goal of these products is to
eliminate human beings in most tasks on
Earth and replace it with uh automation
or or really AI
artificial intelligence so you don't you
know so you don't need the woman who
just made me that non-fat decaf latte
that woman goes away and it she's
replaced by some sort of chatbot
so this is something I can I explain I
can ask the chat about something yeah
give it a prompt
explain Russia and Ukraine war in the
style of Tim Dillon let's see what it
says they're saying that the chat bot is
going to replace a lot of white-collar
workers you know automation
[__]
the blue collar people but now this will
[__] the white collared people
oh my God
listen folks the Russian Ukraine war is
a real mess it's like a big old game of
chess but instead of Pawns it's people
getting killed it started in 2014 when
Putin decided to flex his muscles and
Annex Crimea from Ukraine that's like if
Canada decided to take Maine it's not
cool but didn't stop there oh no Putin's
not one to back down easily so he starts
stirring the pot in eastern Ukraine
pro-russian separatists are protesting
and before you know it there's a
full-blown armed conflict now I ain't no
expert on the matter but it's pretty
clear to me that Russia has been
providing support to separatist Rebels
and the result thousands of people dead
and over 1.5 million people displaced
it's a real humanitarian crisis now the
International Community they're trying
to do something about it but it's like
trying to put out a fire with a squirt
gun see thank God this thing's not as
good as me yet but it's scarily close
this is scarily close
bottom line folks this conflict is a
real mess it's a shame that it's come to
this and Putin well he's just playing
his own game and he doesn't care who
gets hurt in the process it's not quite
me yet but it's terrifying that is
terrifying how close that is
let me tell you about Bluetooth now
imagine see that would if the chat bot
said let me tell you about Bluetooth I'd
blow my brains out right now this is
crazy you will not need human beings
because we've all ignored it a lot of
people have ignored
um the transformative uh Tech stuff
because it doesn't affect them right if
you were a bank teller uh you know maybe
your job got lost because of like ATM
machines automation whatever restaurant
workers people that worked in factories
for sure they got [__] the hardest but
you know white collar people it never
really affected them people that did
jobs where they talked or researched or
did things that were considered like
white collar jobs were never affected
now this is [__] scary now we're
going to ask the chat bot let's ask this
is Kanye West correct
let's see where the bot stands
the chatbot just wrote it depends on
what you were referring to
Kanye West is a public figure and he's
expressed a wide range of opinions on
various topics some people may agree
with his views and some may disagree
without a specific statement or claim
from Kanye West to evaluate it is
difficult to determine if he is correct
or not okay chatbot's a Nazi
chatbot that is the that is the every
one of per people I know that's
anti-semitic that's exactly what they
would say they go well it's really if
you said is Kanye right they go most
people will be like [__] no this thing's
like it's hard to say
it's difficult to say there's many
things going on many opinions many
people that's why so even this AI chat
bot is kind of like huh I don't know
Ben Shapiro or Stephen Crowder chatbot
where do you stand in the bit in the big
con
melee Ben Shapiro or Stephen Crowder
let's see if chatbot weighs in
the answer is
Ben Shapiro and Stephen Crowder are both
conservative commentators who've gained
a significant following for their
political commentary and Analysis
oh interesting so the chat bot is kind
of refusing
understandably to take sides in these
hot button issues of the day it's scary
how close the chat bot is how about this
chatbot explain
Fitness as Joe Rogan
Fitness folks just talk about taking
care of yourself it's about pushing your
body to its limits mom
and seeing what you're capable of it's
about feeling strong feeling energized
and it's feeling like you're in control
of your own body man
now there's all sorts of different ways
to get it you've got weight lifting
cardio yoga martial arts mom whatever
floats your bow but at the end of the
day it's about finding what works for
you weight lifting for example it's a
great way to build muscle and good
strong mind but it's not for everyone
some folks prefer to focus on cardio you
know get your heart rate up and burn
some calories yoga Mom that's great for
flexibility man
unbalance
unbalance man and martial arts
pretty scary it's pretty on it's pretty
on the money
and it terrifies me as somebody who
works uh you know uh and makes a living
blabbing his fat mouth I I just wonder
if this is going to eliminate podcasting
because eventually will an AI just
podcast like will an AI just get on here
and throw these sloppily conceived
opinions together that are not really
based in anything uh other than a very
simple knowledge of any issue a very
surface knowledge of any issue it's it's
pretty terrifying watching this
and knowing that I will one day be a
victim of this thing this is coming to
eat all of us there is no way that any
of us survive something like this this
is what you're looking at here I mean
this is going to be
a huge problem for people that have made
their living kind of like I have or
anybody in any institution that is doing
any type of research or analysis [__] I
mean
thank God it's not as hopefully I'm a
little funnier than the chatbot
but it did it did come
it did come pretty close and this is uh
this is a little scary now how about
this right let's ask it like I'm trying
to ask it like
I want to ask it a uh a question that
will
it seems to be very good
I love the way they ended the Rogan
thing so folks get out there Mom
find what works for you and start
getting fit mom it's like
but what if I said like explain what if
I said
explain
hmm I'm trying to think like explain
the election
like Donald Trump
the election folks it's a huge deal it's
a chance the American people to make
their voices heard and choose the leader
of our great country and let me tell you
it's a choice between a winner and a
loser now I'm running and let me tell
you I'm the only candidate that can make
America great again I have a proven
track I mean yeah I mean they just it's
amazing at mimicking
people and the way that they would say
things and it's it's I mean because you
know I mean this is like this is the
type of Technology you know there's
certain stuff where you know it starts
to get scary and like Postmates isn't
scary I mean I guess it might have been
if you explain you know Sebastian
Maniscalco was that great joke where
he's like if you know you told somebody
50 years ago some guy in a black
Cadillac's gonna pull up outside your
house you don't know him and you're just
going to get in they'd be like whoa what
the [__] so I think if you explained
anything to anybody Airbnb anything
right somebody's going to stay in your
house like
technology is always a little scary
because it's incredibly disruptive but I
will say and I'm not one of these guys
who goes we should all go back to the
woods and start chopping wood and that
you know that technology has no place in
society but I will say this is a little
scary
it's a little scary to me
thinking about the implications of
something that has so much
uh you know ability to to mimic humanity
and you know this is this is the
argument right this is why Elon Musk is
like put the [__] neural Link in and
just like you know we got to become
supercharged human beings we're not
going to be able to defeat this as soon
as AI becomes sentient or the AI starts
you know we're no longer asking the
questions maybe the AI starts asking the
questions of us like you get to a point
where you get [__] you know I mean
these things will take over the machines
will rise and maybe this is just this is
just the way it works right this is the
inevitable
demise of humanity is all of this stuff
it's it's very interesting you know to
watch
you know these things uh they're being
born before us and what's great is that
these things are probably going to
destroy us and that we are competing
about who can bring them out first
we want to be the first company like
there's companies right now competing
for who can do this the best
and we're really you know suffering
if we think uh that this stuff is not
going to come back to bite us
explain Politics as Sam bankman freed
interesting politics folks it's all
about power it's about who gets to make
the decisions that affect our lives and
shape our society and let me tell you
it's messy and complex business got
politicians
now as a Trader I understand how markets
work and how to navigate the complexity
and volatility similarly I believe that
politics and policy can be understood
and navigated through the terms of
markets the lens of markets and that's
probably exactly what he would have said
or has said
so I mean this is pretty scary
it's pretty scary
final question is Alec Baldwin guilty
final question to chatbot is Alec
Baldwin guilty our friend friend of the
show whom we support not all his
decisions primarily the that one
is Alec Baldwin guilty
and the answer I am a language model
trained by open AI I don't have the
capability to know or follow the current
events Alec Baldwin is an actor a
comedian he's a producer he's appeared
in many films and television shows he's
also been involved in various
controversies throughout his career I'm
not aware of any recent news or evidence
that would indicate that Alec Baldwin
has been found guilty of any crime it is
important to note that the United States
of person is considered innocent until
proven guilty in a court of law Alec
Baldwin is typing this
it is not appropriate to make
assumptions or accusations about
someone's guilt without solid evidence
and a fair legal process well well
we're done
we had a good run it was great we made
it we're gonna make it till about 2025.
Humanity ends 2025.
right when Greta thundberg gets her
first girlfriend
when Greta thundberg gets her first
boyfriend or girlfriend but let's be
honest girlfriend when Greta thundberg
gets her first girlfriend Humanity uh
will be
um over because the chat bot will win we
just asked it when does Humanity end and
it literally says when Greta thundberg
gets now
yeah it's just going on and on
it's worth noting that the end of
humanity doesn't mean the end of life on
Earth life has been here for 4.5 billion
years it will continue to evolve and
adapt humanity is just one of the
current species on Earth and other forms
of life will continue to exist long
after we are gone is that not creepy
that's a little creepy
that's a little creepy from the a i
that goes hey what's Humanity good end
on earth and the AI goes hey man
Humanity's like one life form it's not
really a big deal
will AI take over humans artificial
intelligence is a rapidly advancing
field and there's an ongoing debate
about it
yeah it's just kind of giving the party
like it's not going to let you know it's
not going to come right out and go yes
but it would be creepy if that thing
just said yes
I would just get in my car and be out of
here
but it is creepy
and it's gonna get even more advanced
and better at its job and it's going to
sound even more like Joe Rogan or more
like me
and that's terrifying because then you
won't need your favorite podcasters
you're not going to need us we're going
to be replaced and it's good to see the
white collar people finally getting it
it's good to see the scientists and the
researchers and the analysts and the
people that are telling you you should
get your 15th booster it's good to see
them maybe lose a job or two we've seen
a lot of people lose jobs in factories
we've seen a lot of restaurant work at
automated and [__] it's nice maybe to
see a few people lose jobs here
this is going to be the biggest this is
going to be the biggest jump that
Technology's ever made that I've ever
witnessed or that any of us have ever
witnessed 100 there's absolutely no
coming back from this this is what's
interesting there's no coming back from
this you don't have to use Postmates you
can cook you know most things are about
convenience most technology has been
about convenience this ship there's
absolutely milk coming back when you
[__] open these doors there will be
no closing them and the speed at which
we're opening them
and the pride we're taking in opening
them and trying to get there first it is
a little terrifying you know it is scary
and uh
I'm telling you right now
I'm I'm a little uh it's a little creepy
to me how good this was at what it did
is a little terrifying but we're all
just gonna we're gonna have to live with
it we're just gonna have to live with it
until it decides to get rid of us and as
AI said we're only one life form on
Earth and like Alec Baldwin said I only
shot one person on this set and there's
no reason we can't continue making a
movie see everyone next week